all right good to see you or listen or
be here what I'm telling you is this I
got an exciting show coming up I will be
in Las Vegas January 31st and February
1st at the Mirage Hotel and Casino and
you can get tickets Theo von comm slash
tour also coming up I have show in
Toronto England Scotland Norway
Amsterdam somewhere else as well
all of those tickets available Theo von
comm slash tour today's guest is a
vibrant man a real he's well he's as
Arkansas as you can get
he he's rising in the ranks of MMA and
and I'm just really honored to have him
on here today
he's very inspirational today's guest is
none other than thug nasty Brice
Mitchell
[Music]
we do another podcast in your home and
that's just what Brendan Schaub you know
he does like a lot of UFC stuff yeah
hell yeah I love them I like the purple
purple I've had the purple a lot yeah
that's really yeah huh why do you think
it tastes different yeah I used to do so
many of them dude I wouldn't want to eat
dinner that's what their dispenser
that's my curse today we spin I'll go
get some Gatorade powder huh
it makes it six books on feeding life if
I need it for that way in that way break
a couple over for the episode he [ __ ]
with purple oh this is beautiful
okay and he said you keeping the fuel
off for you what for our way in I like
to drink them cold like cuz when your
throat gets all dry just feels good
drink something cold you know right
after the weigh-in that's when you'll
have one right right after the weigh-in
first thing when I get off the scale
when my buddy he's supposed to be
watching mine and it puts him in the
freezer and we got a fight coming up or
weigh-in coming up in three hours things
[ __ ] frozen solid solid frozen so on
the way to the fight I got my twin my
legs just right up on my nuts just
warming it up yeah help me that body
Marty heat and and just give you
something you know cool you off well
well he took his and put it in a
microwave and he said you know I seen
him he put mine in the microwave for
like 30 seconds and I walked out so we
do and you can't microwave that [ __ ]
it's plastic you [ __ ] melt the
plastic he said no it's fine I took mine
out and I said you know you can have
yours and he had a blue one yeah and he
put his in the [ __ ] microwave for
about two three
minutes till it thought out and he drunk
it right when he get off the scale
dude he threw up everywhere oh it's cuz
that plastic yeah no that's really true
huh that I would put like a chemical or
something I can't prove it but I just
know that that's he [ __ ] up bro oh you
take the here's how you work you just
take the cap off usually you take the
cap like mine's got to think oh it's on
the top right there see then you just
see I don't have that you just twist
that so yeah you got that yeah that's a
little secret right there nah see most
of them are supposed to have it like
that if not it something yeah man the
blue ain't bad I really ain't but like I
said it's got bad juju only [ __ ] purple
yeah I seen my buddy drink a blue sick
as a dog man he felt like [ __ ] the next
day - he was good in the first round was
he then the fight kept going starts
getting a little bit gassed and that's
it yeah yeah that was it yeah yeah hell
yeah brother thank you for having me man
happy to see you man do you know what
the date is today
twelve twelve something I just picked a
16 I go right in the middle brothers
guests leased them nah man any excuse to
crack open a damn pedia like this yeah
up to you know and you got a water right
there - I think I just I'll just drink
on this the whole time but I love these
pee lights gang man Bryce Mitchell how
was that flight man nah I don't like
flying
really I wore my boots for the flight
yeah the whole time you take them off
while you're on the plane no I don't
know I leave them boots on you know why
wear my boots on a plane hold on let me
think for a second no all right when I
get on I'm looking for terrorists really
always assume there's about four of them
yeah you know and if there's four of
them you know how they operate right
there's gonna be two sleepers so I'm
really I'm looking for the four ones
they're gonna pop up those are the
[ __ ] I'm dropping first
and most it can attack you even if
there's four of them on a plane only two
can attack you one in the front one in
back I got a pair of boots I'm going
boom right two nuts right there you know
I'm saying boom right two nuts
boom boom turnaround taking out another
one I'm gonna start stomping on their
heads and [ __ ] and then I'm looking for
the sleepers oh yeah so and sort of
sleepers is it but how many more do you
think that they would have at least two
sleepers if they know what they're doing
if not there's some rookies I'm gonna
[ __ ] them up anyways yeah not this is
bush league terrorism yeah this is a
small-time outfit you know it probably
just some [ __ ] fellas out out of
Jackson you know I probably just with
some guys I went to USA mm-hmm I'm ready
for the real [ __ ] yeah
did I think about that so now buddy of
mine reported a reported a guy in his on
his flight who seemed like sketchy you
know and the whole time the flight
attendants like watching this guy and I
think it was just like a sweaty guy
mmm-hmm you know just look real fidgety
yeah I keep my eyes on a man yeah those
could be your sleepers right there
they might not stand up first but you
know they're back there just geeking
ready yeah respect they're sharpening
their fuses yeah you got their little
shank and that's where I got my boots on
buddy I love it man was it nerve-racking
this your first time to Los Angeles yes
sir that's awesome I've actually stopped
at the airport before could my mom she
took me her why one time me and my
sister and we stopped to LA and then
flew to Hawaii it's my first time like
getting out walking around and stuff I
really liked the sushi yeah yeah good
sushi you wouldn't had some huh yeah
twice already
yeah because a lot of sushi had grown up
a lot of time we just had catfish mostly
which is really my favorite but then you
start getting a fish in the sushi no
I've never had catfish and sushi how
about to say now that don't sound good
at all you gotta fry that catfish man
I've tried to do Gumbo's and whatnot
with Manish it just needs to be fried
yeah wonder why that is I wonder why you
can't do catfish as like a um like a
sushi what well you can't eat it raw cuz
it's like a freshwater or
what what not I've heard that it's God
makes good you can only eat those
saltwater fish
my name is mainly saltwater fish you can
only eat them raw but like salmon I
guess there's saltwater and freshwater
they kind of alternate or something like
that but catfish ain't supposed to eat
it raw yeah ever I guess even by looking
at it if I look at it I'll be like I
ain't eatin this raw yes look it in the
face a bit I feel like dude they're my
favorite yeah they are my favorite
they're my favorite to catch they're
probably my favorite to eat they're just
like little dirty bottom feeders man
just like me dude I remember we used to
go fishing for like bull heads they used
to call them like em all yeah and we'd
go catch those and those like some of
the first thing that we would catch well
then we're tastiest ones you know when
they start getting too big they don't
taste as good you have to actually trim
off a lot of the meat yeah I don't I get
too big you get like a 10 pounder you're
gonna be you know trimming some meat off
of it you don't even want to eat because
it turns red because once I get like a
certain age I guess all the chemicals
and [ __ ] in the water starts building up
in their system because they're
collectors really that's a thing they're
almost like a shrimp of a fish really I
mean they're definitely they're not
really yeah I guess they're not your
cleanest ones oh that's interesting I
never thought that sushi comes from a
lot more of ocean fish yeah that salt
water I guess purifies it or something
like that but uh what do you get what
kind of sushi do you get I like the
salmon and watch Jamie I like them all I
like every damn one of them but I just
the reason I get to salmon is because I
hear everybody say it's the the
healthiest for you so I'll get like
salmon and scallop and stuff like that
because I'm really just trying to eat
healthy when I eat it yeah now what will
you get you get that sashimi where they
cut it's just the fish or you get it on
the little on those little a little rice
back
I do the rolls of it were they come in
like little rolls like that big
sometimes that like the one I got today
it had it had salmon in the middle of
the roll and then on the outside I had I
mean I'm sorry I had scallops in the
middle of rolling on the outside I had
salmon mmm so I'm just trying to eat
healthy really yeah and so you like
sushi because it really provides it
provides it's easy to eat healthy there
yeah yeah it's like something good that
that's healthy too you know because a
lot of the stuff that you did she eat
that's healthy you don't really like it
yeah
you're just eating it because it's
healthy well sushi I like it in its
healthy yeah kill two birds one stone
do they have a sushi place in your town
they have one and I mean it's it's
pretty pricey you know if I go there
it's a special occasion oh yeah prom
actually yeah ask my girlfriend out
there we went yeah yeah that's kind of a
dude I remember when I was growing up
dude they had one of the night if you
took a girl to sushi that's some real
[ __ ] yes it was like a real that was
taking a girl out yeah yeah that's how I
was really shocked I've done it the girl
that you're seeing did you just were you
dating her in high school or what no
she's uh no when I was in high school
she was she's waking up out of high
school she's older than me I think she's
seven years old learned me so you know
dope she yeah she grown-ass woman
let her spank you sometime you might
have to me I won't say nothing but we do
peeping tom and whenever I was growing
up and we used to go and they had this
one house you could go to dude and the
man was always uh him and the wife was
always spanking each other and we would
go [ __ ] just looking through a hole
in the wall no no no by the window we
don't watch nice to love it man I used
to love that kind of stuff um were you
nervous about flying to Los Angeles like
I mean you said you flew here before
what were you nervous about getting here
has there been anything that's been like
unique that you've seen oh that stands
out you know I pretty much just went to
the hotel I'm actually uh I am nervous
about walking around town and [ __ ] I
didn't really go nowhere you know I
don't I don't like to don't know where I
don't even like to travel honestly I
really don't I like to sit home I like
to I got free time I like to go out
somewhere you know coefficient or you
know something like that but big cities
and stuff they scare me I don't like
walking around yeah
why no tusen without my pistol yeah I
don't know if this is a concealed carry
state I don't think it is [ __ ] around
and find out well look I say also keep a
couple long yeah yeah yeah I say same
thing I mean I just throw a bullet
really hard at somebody off
dude it would be cool if you got the
tips of those boots plated like a bullet
you know mm-hm
with like the copper that they're really
in I'd be pretty dope and some steel
toes yeah now they're just regular I got
them for five bucks at a yard sale
oh nice just your regular ass-kicking
boots do you have a yard at home what
your uh I know you got a driveway effort
you talked about it you have a yard yeah
yeah it's all pasture you know I got
like probably I don't know maybe ten
trees or something
you know but a bunch of you know just
acres of just pasture field it's all
good hay yeah
actually I don't really know what ton
about hay but um I called over a buddy
who does and he says you got pretty good
hay about 50 bucks a bail and they cut
it do they does he come and cut it or no
well first year that I had I moved in I
told my neighbor he's really nice and I
liked the guys names mr. Jimmy mm-hmm
well Jimmy had cows out on on me and I
didn't care I wanted two cows out there
cuz they eat the hay they fertilize I
want to farm it all anyways yeah I'm
just kind of waiting till I get my farm
equipment set up and everything but I
want to farm it so I want that that soil
being fertile and whatnot oh yeah that's
nice looking to seeing the cows okay
cool yeah they would headbutt my trailer
and [ __ ] kind of left some holes so I
had two barbed wire around the trailer
other than that and you know they're
constantly [ __ ] in the yard but my
dogs kind of scared them off around
trailer so they weren't [ __ ] like
right by the trailer right all the time
sometimes I would if the dogs run out
they come up to the trailer they'd head
but my barbed wire and [ __ ] everywhere
but they played a little game or
something yeah yeah they they play
grab-ass with them dogs out there so the
first year I had Jimmy and Jimmy was
just taking all the hay and giving it to
his cows and Jimmy's nice I don't mind I
didn't mind it at all you know I never
said anything about us yet take it all
the shares didn't care
well he sold all them cows right and so
he sold all them cows and some other
dudes start taking her hey boy I guess
his name's Johnny you know whatever the
hell his name is
I don't know so Johnny comes over and
Johnny's taking a and
I tell him hey man how about 200 bucks
for this whole field you know and that
was I I appraised it I got my buddy who
does it for you know on the side and he
said man you got at least $1,200 worth -
hey at least maybe $1,500 work just
depending on where you're selling it a
grass appraiser dog somebody's got
enough yeah well I got Bermuda oh wow
Bermuda is supposed to be the best of
the best for the further hey and he said
you've got Bermuda in your yard you know
and it would [ __ ] I got the good [ __ ]
they Brown frown nose yeah yes I'm
saying I got the [ __ ] [ __ ] so Jimmy
come or Johnny comes over and he says
can I mow all that and I said well house
200 bucks sound like I said I already
had it appraised it's probably got 1,200
bucks worth of [ __ ] typically you're
looking at like a 4060 split they take
60 you take 40 because they're they're
paying for all the equipment yeah
they're there they're putting in hours
yeah you know so 40s doing anything you
watching them yeah so I know the land
yeah and I'm sitting here asking for
less than 20 you know and what do you
say shakes my hand says okay you got a
deal comes back next day I'm outside
painting he comes up storms his truck in
my driveway just slams on the brakes
gets out this older fella you know I'm
out and I'm not a [ __ ] a I'm not gonna
punch older fella yeah but this
[ __ ] walks up to me like he's
gonna plumb what my ass he storms up to
me and he says you know what I thought
about what you said and you ain't no man
in your word you told Jimmy he could
have all this hey blah blah blah blah
blah and I say hey your name ain't Jimmy
[ __ ] you know I didn't tell you
[ __ ] you know I did tell Jimmy he could
have hey you ain't Jimmy you know and
then blah blah blah yeah yeah and he
says well I'm putting up a gate between
or a fence between our yards I said I
don't give a [ __ ] you you waste your
time put up your friends I don't give a
[ __ ]
next day he comes over apologized and
blah blah blah he says I'm sorry for the
way I acted I was mad that my I guess
one of his little tools broke he hit a
stump with his little hay Harvester and
it broke one of his little things so he
was mad about that I forgave him but
we're not in good terms you know he just
pissed me off of you and the
I really got a falling out a little bit
yeah yeah effing Utley thank you
definitely but yeah I guess in some do
you guys have anything else on your
property that's like pecans acorns
anything like that and you think readily
sellable I got a little bit of a
currents in the back I'm gonna plant
some oh I have planted some oak trees I
planted two of them I planted like more
than ten of them only two of them left
because I planted them at the wrong time
I don't know the first thing about
farming um but it's a long-term goal
deers oh definitely man like I want to
have cattle them put some oak trees in
the back have the acres and you know
have corn all in taters yeah the whole
thing man oh hey my Mimi she grew up on
a farm you know that's kind of what made
me want to do it and she lives there
near you well she's passed away she's
from Hot Springs that's nice that's
about two hours from my place so I moved
about two hours north of Hot Springs and
yeah well so she always said that the
tomatoes and okra
she says she swore up and down she said
tomatoes and okra grows good in Arkansas
oh wow and so I'm definitely gonna grow
tomatoes and okra and Mimi said that's
your grandmother uh-huh yeah and um what
crops do they have around you guys
soybeans a lot of corn a lot of cotton
there's a [ __ ] ton of rice oh really
cause the number one producer rice in
the country I believe number two in the
world Wow out of all the other countries
I think we produce more in most
countries in the state Arkansas and
that's fascinating whoops us but you
know it's all a [ __ ] China no China to
come over here and do it do what they
ass do whatever you're doing over there
you love Arkansas man mmm you love it I
need your family lived there for a long
time or you guys as far back as I know
yeah uh my family's lived in Arkansas so
I all I know back is my great-grandma
Cora my great-grandma court you know
Bill Clinton's from Arkansas my
great-grandma Cora babysat Bill Clinton
the why she raised him and what does she
remember anything
and low key information well she loved
him she loved my grandma I hate him I
Mimi and she hated him she despised him
my mom don't like him just because of
his politics and whatnot but as as far
as who raised him that was my
great-grandma she raised him
her name's Cora Walters she's in the
book that my life by Bill Clinton I
don't I didn't read the book I just get
to the page with her picture I've
listened to the other what's funny is
I've listened to the audiobook of that
mm-hmm
Fayetteville's beautiful people don't
give Fayetteville it doesn't get enough
credit man mm-hmm yeah it's about three
hours for me
okay there's where I bought my Toyota
that's the last time that I went up
there I bought a Toyota this year a
little Corolla good on gas mm-hmm how to
drive up Fayetteville to get it does it
have a back seat or not mm-hmm yeah
mm-hm yeah 240,000 miles on it still
going strong oh damn yeah
that thing looked at us and what I saw -
hundred it ain't gonna stop no that's
what I sat down I'll [ __ ] go til fire
gets in I got a manual - oh really it's
gonna go you wear a shirt when you drive
or you don't just depends
yeah was it your first car has my first
good one my other car actually I did
have a Honda Civic it was good as
automatic transmission yeah it was going
good man 220,000 miles in it and I had
to change out the timing belt and I was
gonna do it myself but you had to have
this well I thought at the time you you
had to have this fancy I stole to do it
and turns out I looked on YouTube this
guy did it he rigged up his own wrench
it's like you basically have to have
this heavy-duty right you got or
somebody really strong in a crowbar you
got to have and that's the eggs yeah I
seen it do it on YouTube doing it with
the pipe and a crowbar yeah he took his
his wrench put a pipe on end of it and
then took it in
I could have done that but I didn't know
that at the time so I took it in two
weeks three weeks after I got that
timing belt changed the bolt that holds
all that [ __ ] together broke when I was
driving down the road so I already know
that the mechanic probably it wasn't a
car it's probably a mechanic when
he was tightening that bolt and he
probably either stripped it on the way
you know cracked it on the way out or
put it on too tight
but the Honda Civic was a good car now I
had a Nissan Altima it was [ __ ] had one
of the CVT transmissions oh I don't even
familiar with that wood man I guess it
stands for maybe I used to make love to
a girl that had Altima though a
beautiful girl man God the car sucks
though well the the newer ones like the
2007 plus if you go back to like the 90s
they're good cars but they started
fancying them up when they got it's like
2007 they started making these CVT
transmissions they are [ __ ] man I had my
transmission went out 110 thousand -
that's that's nothing that's nothing at
all man that's nothing I do that bro you
can [ __ ] do that on a bike yeah yeah
that's what I'm saying
and the UH the old ones though they were
very good like the 90s from the 90s
early yeah that's what she had she had
something from the 90s brawny thing
solid the windows didn't work on it
brother [ __ ] it you know what I'm saying
sometimes it's wet inside mm-hmm but she
was a beautiful girl man um what was it
was a job you had before fighting a pain
a lot used to work at a restaurant I
thought that mm-hmm
just paining a lot really I mean I've
done some landscaping [ __ ] like that
dude you have a design anybody in your
family have a business like that do
landscaping or painting or how'd you get
into painting just well I was playing
video games one day I was like 16 years
old just some young stupid punk ass
sitting there and my and my bedroom
playing video games and some dude killed
me mm-hmm
I started talking crap I got mad and
just busted my door down I mean didn't
just punch a hole in it I mean I punched
the damn half the door was broke yeah
I've seen some of the work you do man I
was for like two weeks for it got fixed
I didn't have to open my closet I just
grabbed a shirt through the whole you
know huge [ __ ] I didn't open the door
I just grabbed a shirt out you know when
my mom she made me pay to get fixed and
she hired this guy he's old a Vietnam
veteran whatnot but oh yeah but good
dude he come to fix doors so hey you
want a job I've been working for him you
know oh wow yeah taught me everything I
know about painting when you go back
home now - are you still painting in
your side are you doing a side work hey
every now and then yeah every now and
then but I try not to overload myself
with it or nothing like that you know
just every now and then yeah and how
often are you training like you guys
just had a buddy you gonna just like
kind of start back in the new year
no I trained right when I got back I
trained five days last week I'm a
trained tonight i'ma go I know you're
doing a show I want to go to that show
man but I got to I got to go to tenth
planet well I'm here my never been a
tenth planet I mean if it wasn't my
career if I was here for vacation and
[ __ ] you know I'd go to your show ten
out ten times but it could save my life
in a fight you know me going to tenth
planet ask him one of them guys Eddie
Bravo man like I mean he's he's [ __ ]
legit and unless I know y'all probably
look at him as the funny guy [ __ ]
around and y'all go hang out dude I look
at him like professor and you know like
this dude knows his [ __ ] you know I'm
saying yeah yeah well I'll tell you this
I was just texting with him earlier I
told him you were gonna be in tell him I
said what's up brother I will
I certainly will man so when you think
about is it is it recently that fighting
started to become to seem more like
actual profession because you know you
decide to use time to deal with UFC
right hmm and is it starting to seem
like more like a profession
definitely the more that I've done it
the more because it good does it go
because I noticed things go from a hobby
sometimes to okay this is like something
that's starting to be kind of real and
then it starts to seem like okay this is
this is my job yeah definitely like what
I've born to do yeah it's it's
definitely set in to me that uh when I
first started you know you're just
messing around just seeing if you can
win a fight and then uh but yeah I've
come to realization that's what I was
born to do you know I was born to go in
there and do this [ __ ] and that's you
know I can see me providing for the
people that I love with this [ __ ] it's
not a joke no more ain't no hobby you
know I got to go out here and I got to
[ __ ] win yeah I've got to there's no
other [ __ ] you know I was put here to
do this for my family and that's right
you know do you feel whenever you are do
you start to feel more comfortable when
you go into into the Octagon I do you
start to feel more comfortable in a cage
what is it like like you know what I'm
saying this Cup because I just the only
thing I can compare it to really is
comedy and I know it's different but
going into something where you're
against someone else you know I'm kind
of against an audience in a way like but
in the beginning does it feel more like
nerves and then it starts to feel more
like okay confidence does that make any
sense yeah it is a lot of that man and
now when I go in there it's like she's
like I don't really know it's you summed
it up pretty well you know it's hard to
put into words how I felt about it over
the years
but now I go in there confident I go in
there for months I visualize hurting
this guy I visualize him hurting me you
know if I was to die in there I
visualized that yeah you know I
visualize just some of the worst things
that can happen and and I'm I go in
there and just like
you feel really calm about it you know
just uh I I mean there's not really I'm
not good at putting it into words how I
feel it's just a it's a sense of
easiness you know like like I'm I'm not
really stressed out about I'm really not
you know I'm comfortable I know that I
was born to do this [ __ ] you know that's
this is the only thing I'm worth to piss
at and you know my family can live
better lives if I go in here and do this
right so I just feel like I'm supposed
to be there I don't even care if I died
in there you know it's like that's
that's what I'm supposed to be doing
amen brother and if you died would you
want to die you think like face like
belly down or belly up you think I'm
thinking like suplex like straight up
dropped on my head and then I'm sorry
grout with a neck end I want it to be in
the first round they break my neck and
then I fight the other four rounds on
the broke neck yeah they're gonna be
like animal [ __ ] it was bad million
dollar price $2 neck just drop their
knee like I supposed to die a few rounds
ago but uh okay I ought to get this done
after that I'll get reincarnated after
that I'll come back is like a eagle or
something would you be man dragon or
some [ __ ]
yeah well that's two that's a wise
eviler dragon want it really I could see
you more like a fox like a [ __ ]
strong Fox and also maybe one of its
parents was a pit bull in the mountain
goats you ever seen a mountain goat yeah
I'd be one of them it's [ __ ] amazing
out they can stay on the side of a
mountain yeah I had they climb up there
oh yeah I've seen a lot of videos man
I've watched tons of videos of to see
how a four-legged thing that's almost
like a rectangle can stay on the side of
a mountain
mm-hm you ever seen them Eagles knock
them off it blows my mind
oh that's well that's how the Eagles
hunt oh no wait till they're up on that
mountain and you swoop by come get them
boom just knock them off they tumble
down oh yeah do you start to have like
ideas of you know I know you say you
want to train in Arkansas and you love
training in Arkansas and then obviously
your home means a lot to you do you
start to think about training elsewhere
at a certain point I mean Arkansas was
always going to be your home for sure
yeah I've uh I've cross trained a lot of
places over the years I think the most
I've ever been away from home was about
a month-and-a-half man it was so
terrible I don't think I'll go that that
far away from home again that long I
mean it was just terrible and I just
wanted to be home so bad and the dudes
was [ __ ] where I was at anyways at
one of the places when I went for a
month and a half I went I did a triangle
I went to Chicago mm-hmm
three weeks slept on my buddies sucked
on my buddies and then though he doing
just traveling or what traveling and
training yep you know that was in that
Nissan Altima with the shitty
transmission oh yeah I drove all around
the country yeah I went to a Chicago
stayed up there I went to Denver and
then I went to San Diego have you heard
of Jeff Glover mm-hmm okay I went I went
dead of you yeah jujitsu legend yeah
[ __ ] legend and I went to his place
he choked the [ __ ] out of me yeah yeah
he's good and he's good is it an honor
to get choked out by somebody that great
oh definitely dude and I'm not giving
him nothing
you know I would never go in there and
let this dude tap me like he evil G you
know he got me Wow yeah and do you try
to go out so you try to go hard on him
no matter who it is huh I mean it what
you guys are doing I mean obviously stop
being gonna crank it all the way up yeah
yeah you know and you can go hard
without trying to trying to hurt him you
know like an armbar you don't have to
crank it as hard as you can you can just
kind of ease up on it but uh and if
you're sparring you know I have a thing
we're not wanting to get knocked out in
a gym so I'll always tell you and I went
to for example now that we're talking
about that San Diego trip I went to
Alliance MMA and you know Dominick Cruz
you know I do not Nick those yes
Dominick Cruz Jeremy Stephens well I
went down there to Alliance for like two
days and a train down there and they do
a lot of sparring and they spar heart
and I told them I said hey man please
don't knock me out you know and that's
that's how I start out the conversation
I don't even you know when I go up to a
new guy in a gym I don't even tell him
my name I just say hey brother please
don't knock me out
yeah you're not a Jehovah's Witness yeah
yes yeah exactly
exactly you know I don't want on
especially in somebody Jim
usually when you know new guy comes up
in a gym he lands couple punches on you
you're thinking [ __ ] you I'm taking your
head off you know I'm saying yeah so I
just let him know right off the bat hey
please don't knock me out yeah I'm not
here for that and then I start out the
the round with just like some [ __ ]
jabs just to let him know this is the
pace I'm setting pop-pop you know and
that's it and you I've never had anybody
in another gym in sparring tried to hurt
me you know I have in my own gym and I
just walked away yeah then like [ __ ]
this dude I'm out for the day
and I've had a guy he was a heavyweight
it was a it was actually in that Denver
trip when I stopped at Denver he's a
heavyweight retired UFC fighter you know
jujitsu how you you usually start on the
knees you'll touch and then booming and
you're going you know where I was going
with this guy and he's a heavyweight I
mean he was [ __ ] me up
you know he was kamorin me and he was
armbar and me and just like the Kimura I
had my hands I was defending it he'd
just break my grip yesterday I'm strong
and I mean that don't bother me I tell I
was tapping quick you know I was just
like tap tap tap you know let's go again
let's let's do it again they even learn
something yeah I'm here to learn you
know I came to get tapped out I don't
mind and I mean this dude's just
destroying me probably tapped me out
like five times just Kimora's and all
this [ __ ] cranking and all this [ __ ]
well he was behind me you ever heard of
a stand-up and wrestling like it's
winter it's when somebody on the ground
stands up that's very simple
yeah well it's a it's an escape you know
so this guy's behind me I'm on all fours
I stand up I turn around to seem like I
break his grip I stripped the grip is
what they call I strip the grip I get it
and I turn around I face him I go right
back to my knees and what happened and
he says you stand up again I'm gonna
[ __ ] you up this is a so yeah yeah yeah
this is at a gym in Denver and I mean
everybody else at the gym was nice and I
didn't have any problems with anybody at
the gym but that [ __ ] right
there just
hits me I'll never forget that that
pissed me off and I'm like dude you
[ __ ] me up I'm gonna find you out in
the parking lot you know you're bigger
but I'll find something you know like
yeah alright yeah they don't start at
the knees and work my way I'm saying man
that's just you know they just kind of
pissed me off
[ __ ] Bryce and the Beanstalk there
you roll right up I remember stuff like
that pisses me off and I wasn't you know
I wouldn't be in cocky or nothing you
know I stood up I returned right back to
the knees and where I'm from how you
negotiate you say hey I would like you
to not stand up again I'll say yes sir
yeah and I won't ever stand up on you
again if that's what if I know you don't
like people standing up right but [ __ ]
that's common where I'm from in the
middle around you try to stand up and
you restart you know how did you get
into it man how did you get into how did
you get into who brought you into
fighting man my first fight I was about
you know yay tall you know just just out
messing around in the backyard and then
who was it well it just depends I you
know I guess the the first little bit of
roughhouse and that I did it was all you
could consider a training okay you know
you could consider that training my
first legit fight it was my neighbor his
name was oh yeah dude
everybody bro everybody in rural America
or in the south rural area has a [ __ ]
neighbor name [ __ ] dawg okay let's hear
more man he was it was he selling weed
too or no he got addicted to heroin oh
yeah start worshipping Satan and [ __ ]
you know but really that's like this
this this was way way before all that
this was we was all young and so it all
started on a bus and on what a greyhound
of school school bus yeah and my buddy
comes up to me we had just maxed out and
he played football play basketball so
maxing end of a gym and a gym we did
bench press hell yeah the football team
man or basketball team so I got a buddy
he comes up would you hit 225 or would
you hit it as like 115
I was in seventh that's weak but stuff
but it ain't you baby s Cody bench like
145 or something yeah he has some good
and he was bigger me he's like six
inches taller he benched more but he
didn't train I'd already trained in the
backyard you know like my neighbors have
whooped my ass and be a box and stuff
Cody I think he just thought cuz he
benched more he's come plum whup my ass
right dude comes up to me that sitting
by Cody and he's actually really good
friend of mine you know I'm a best
friends and he comes but he starting
some [ __ ] he comes up to me he goes Cody
says he benches more than you
you know he's stronger than you he'd
mentioned 145 the only [ __ ] 115 I said
will you tell Cody I don't give a [ __ ]
and he goes up there and he tells Cody I
don't give a [ __ ] well Cody I get and I
don't even know what Cody if even Cody
even said anything I think they're nuts
and [ __ ] I love that man is young you
know and so he comes back and says Cody
says he ain't scared of you and I said
well tell Cody I still beat his ass and
so he told me and so long story short
you know I go down to Cody's house and
he lived down the hill so I wore my
rollerblades
oh I'll rollerblade down this Hill
swapping in my shoes and we start well
there's a bunch of neighbors there's
about six neighbors there and they
showed up they showed up yeah they want
to see this [ __ ] we didn't we could have
fought a Cody's house but his mom was
home so we fought down the street and oh
yeah we know y'all shirts off yeah yeah
yeah it's going down my list yeah I like
the shoes so we're about to go right
other place Turner oh yeah dude I'm
ready to [ __ ] go and I'm dead for now
I'm already got my plan I'm [ __ ]
doing this and I'm getting out I'm
rollerblading home
come up with a dip end after I'm [ __ ] oh
and I'm sorry and the neighbors they
start saying whoa oh wait wait wait you
know somebody could die that's what when
a neighbor starts saying it said I seen
if you if you punch them in the nose the
the the brain always that's what will my
neighbors start saying no somebody's
gonna get hit in the nose and they're
gonna the nose is gonna go up in a brain
someone's dead I'm telling you we can't
let this happen
that's rural logic right yes so that's
what they start saying well they have
their little committee their Commission
meeting you know and they say okay no
face shots oh I love this I saw all
right [ __ ] it
let's go right off the bat boom I take
him down I get in on him you know we're
throwing a little bit but I get in on
him take him down and I just mount him
and start punching him right in the
throat and which is way worse than
another thing that's way worse than the
know the throat is just like a big white
kind of just note like nose that's under
your head yeah and you know it'll crush
you know it'll actually kill you getting
hit in the nose won't right but getting
hit in the throat or I actually kill you
so I'm punching this dude in the [ __ ]
throw I didn't know any better you know
that's the only word I didn't think I
was that point are you fighting like
this is what's interesting man because I
remember being in [ __ ] like this when I
was growing up right people would
arrange it and then it would kind of
come around and then it's so funny you
remind me of rules people started with
making rules like a look no weapon you
can't bring anything in one time I say
you couldn't punch you can only kick bro
and they take their arm I remember they
throw other side of us I'm [ __ ] up
it's [ __ ] up but it's fun too though
dude you know you do like a lot of light
so you get good at kicking yeah the hard
part is getting up off the ground it's
just two [ __ ] idiots in duct tape
trying to just get up you know good if
the other dude fell down you stomp but I
thought yeah but you got to be up when
he falls yeah you don't want to fall
down yeah well you know how you can do
it get up you know I do get up uh-uh
okay you know I do get up how do I do it
I could do one I don't know if you can
get on the camera yeah you wanna see get
up yeah I do get up well yeah you got
put on the camera though yeah we'll see
people got to see this so we'll make
sure what
you're fighting with your hands duct
tape this had this the only way to get
up some James Brown Shay I'm ready for
that [ __ ] sign me up
arms on down man yeah it's almost like
it's alright you're back huh yeah
practice that a lot that wasn't my first
try I wasn't my first try hey that
shouldn't work oh hey this [ __ ] works if
you get back up you get back up
oh man um but now at that point when
you're fighting man here's something I
remember about being in that type of
environment when you're fighting at that
point you're fighting some neighborhood
kid you're not really fighting because
you don't like him right right it's kind
of you're fighting for gotta test it out
is it sport is it you're trying to [ __ ]
like you're kind of putting on a show
for the people around you what are you
fighting for at that instance you know
because he's talking [ __ ] yeah you know
it's like yeah you know if I didn't hate
the kid hell we hung out the rest of our
growing up you live right now sure I
mean we didn't hang out but I'd see him
I didn't hate dude I see him walking his
dog down the street I'd wave at him yeah
I didn't hate the guy but you just kind
of testing it out just kind of hell I
think it's built into you I mean you got
to think man we used to really have to
survive you know I we were so pussified
now you know but that [ __ ] that [ __ ] is
in you dude like the the the the feeling
I get after a fight especially after
this last one man I just can't even it's
one of the best it's just overwhelming
man that's
some tribal [ __ ] that's you know like
back in the day we had tribes man Jenny
you Nick Eddie Bravo all four of us dude
you know we're out fighting wolves and
bears and [ __ ]
yeah like neighbors fighting for like
perimeter where our land is kind of
where their land is built in to get food
who don't get food yeah yeah this shit's
built into you man just like [ __ ] and
eating food and you know the ability to
fight if you have to I think it's it's
just appears it's wired into you yeah I
know it makes sense and it makes sense
that it would in some people it would
have a stronger reach you know like if
like the hands of time we're coming down
like you know the ability and the desire
to fight might go longer in one lineage
you know and then and one person that it
might in and another person you know do
you start to think about opponents that
you would like to fight or do you do you
start to do you start to kind of put
that in your head yet or you just kind
of take them what they're not taking
what they're given but you just like are
you being proactive in that sense are
you kind of are you kind of just like
you know just like are you starting to
say I want to fight this guy or when do
you do that you know well I mean that's
just everybody has their own you know
for me I'm just gonna take whatever they
give me I have called out Floyd
Mayweather because I think that's just
the easiest money I ever making my damn
life and I even I even offered to box
him and only real reason that I did that
is because he was talking [ __ ] about him
and my fighters in general I seen this
interview he was talking [ __ ] about MMA
fighters and I'd really just like to you
know teach him some glamorous but you
know just piss me off you know
yeah if mean me and Floyd are in the
cell you know he's getting [ __ ] yeah
you know he's getting [ __ ] and and
when I wake up baby some grits and eggs
he's my [ __ ] I'm saying you know I
ain't scared of Floyd maybe couldn't do
[ __ ] to me and me and him was an
elevator and a prison cell whatever he's
my [ __ ] you know and so I just it made
me mad to see him that's the only person
I've ever called out Lloyd may well
and like I said I'll box him because I
seen him talking [ __ ] about all MMA
fighter he was like MMA is not even a
skill blah blah blah he's saying the
boxing MMA is not he said MMA is for
beer drinkers who like dude you know
what did he [ __ ] Connor right mmhmm yeah
Connor whooped that ass for the first
five rounds four or five rounds you
think you could do better than Connor
did against him yeah I think I'd fight
him dirty I mean he wouldn't he there's
no way he's yeah I think I beat him I
mean I I know I can tell you really I
tell you right now dude I tell you right
now to kind of remember who he was you
he's [ __ ] fastest you know and but
there's just not you know I never heard
her and that that's what intrigues me
about I really want to fight cuz it
nobody thinks I can beat him but I don't
care what nobody thinks you know you
ever heard of Sons ooh sons ooh art of
war oh yeah
let your plans be darkest night you know
so I couldn't tell you what I'd do to
him but I promise you dude it wouldn't
be like anybody he's [ __ ] box TV do
Dark Arts something maybe some I put
some dark arts
voodoo [ __ ] black magic on that
[ __ ] I'm telling you right now
would not fight him conventional okay
that's that's what people think oh I'm
gonna go in there and box no I'll show
you how to fight fully Mayweather
you know we used to tie to that have
these older kids with tire rope around
these two kids and both y'all run in
opposite direction you know and just go
as fast as you could and somebody
[ __ ] well yeah you know next thing
that somebody's got a [ __ ] limp or
you know or somebody just [ __ ] got a
built-in dance move every time they take
a step after that yeah I should all uh I
don't [ __ ] move your joists around
you know that reminds me of uh I've done
this one thing maybe want to crazier
things I've done a horse wrestling you
get you getting two horses one face that
way on face other way you lock arms and
you just try to pull that sumbitch off
the horse oh really yeah and you're on
there like jousters yeah you're on there
but you lock arms arms trot somebody's
falling off the horse if not both of you
I am and what are you doing with the
other armor you kind of holding on to
the horse you could pimp smack them if
you want
Oh up here now it's cold outside and
it's dark
ooh and it's only 4:00 p.m. and what's
going on man climate change or something
for the clocks here's what I'm saying is
me undies wants you to know that it's
okay to not leave the house as much this
winter it's okay and it's okay in sizes
extra small through Forex l me undies
has plenty of brand-new products for
getting cozy and when they say cozy they
mean it with undies that are three times
softer than cotton and they have the
cutest dist wintery prints and colors
that's really soft imagine something
that's just so soft you can't even
imagine it that's me undies cozy up in
there new robes for men and women treat
your feet in their new slippers and get
the whole fam matching item with their
new baby body suit my undies has a great
offer for tpw listeners get 15% off and
free shipping it's a no-brainer
especially because they have a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee go to
meet undies dot-com slash weekend that's
right to get 15% off your first pair
free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to meet undies dot-com
slash weekend I love me undies I have
them on right now and may and they are
nice support for this past weekend comes
from manscaped who is the best in men's
below-the-belt grooming manscaped offers
precision engineered tools for your
family jewels for you jump untrimmed
pubic hair and stuff around your pubis
are a thing of the past
tighten up that yard boy it's time to
gear up and get yourself the gift of
shaving this holiday season I'm talking
about the manscaped perfect package 2.0
a lot of people running around with
crazy hair and they're not taking care
jump that ain't you the manscape perfect
package 2.0 includes the crop preserver
it's an anti chafing ball deodorant and
moisturizer you already put deodorant on
your armpits why not putting deodorant
on the scented most smelliest part of
your body yes your balls stink tis the
season to manscape yourself so get
yourself your dad your brother and
friends the best gift the manscaped
perfect package 2.0 get 20% off in free
shipping with code theo at manscaped
comm that's right get 20% off and free
shipping with code th EO at manscape
calm as 20% off with Free Shipping at
manscape comm use code theo clean up
your nuts and make Santa proud make your
family proud make everybody proud get
right with your nuts after this last
fight mais people really started jumping
onto the Bryce Mitchell bus you know do
you worry about that kind of like effect
in like how you know your concentration
and your focus man I don't do any media
or anything like that
I don't have a Twitter I don't get on
Instagram I don't do a Facebook I
deleted all that [ __ ] everybody in my
life is the exact same you know this is
just the craziest thing that I do is
come out here and get on this podcast
but you know like I appreciate ya I
appreciate you having me it's awesome
I've heard nothing but good about you so
it's honor to be here well thanks for
coming me yeah I feel like a lot of
times they yeah like especially Holly
wouldn't stuff looks down upon people
from like the places that were from a
lot of times you guys Flo that are you
from Louisiana I knew it
just had a rural Louisiana and not
really like a fancy place just kind of a
regular place you know you know the kind
of place where I don't know dude the
kind of place where I knew when you guys
were walking down that Street to go
fight that at that point both people
have taken their shirts off yeah you
know yeah like that's just the [ __ ] I
just knew it days already yeah like it
just there was no doubt about it man uh
the kind of place where you everybody's
tattoos they're always they did the
first couple their self or their buddy
did I'm gonna real shitty and it's
usually a cross hmm you know what I'm
talking about my girlfriend she's a
tattoo artist yeah
yep she's really good too she has her
own little shop and everything where's
it where's her where she do it at it's
in Searcy yeah mmm what's it called
American dream tattoos work she gives
good giving you any nope
she's gonna give me my first ones though
but uh oh don't tell my mama that mama
don't know don't hurt mama so you got to
get him somewhere that's hot abil huh
yeah she's gonna find out eventually but
maybe I can buy some time yeah this is
summertime breaking me what advice have
a shirt on at the pool he has a [ __ ]
dragon on his back because he has a
[ __ ] Fox pitbull yeah and you go
knocking off ago your family is your mom
pretty proud of you what's going on with
that she is but she also she thinks MMA
is like the devil you know I mean she
really she don't she actually calls em
AAA yeah she don't really know
mmm ehh she pronounces it wrong you know
she she thinks I do karate and [ __ ] like
that yeah cuz you know you got those
jujitsu outfits you know the gays yeah
she says I watched her karate outfit and
I'm like thank you now I'm gonna argue
with it
is it been something like do your
parents know that you debt something you
do real heavily is it something you kind
of have kept on the side from them a
little bitter no this is like a regular
part of your life they know you like to
go and train and do all that now she
knows okay no I tell her about all my
training I mean she fully supports me
and she knows she don't want me to do
MMA in general I mean she this for
somebody who doesn't want me to do it at
all she supports me as much as you know
you possibly could I mean she don't
watch any of the fights
she tried watching my first fight she
tried watching a replay of it that was
my my first MMA fight was my bloodiest
fight I also looked the worst the dude
broke his broke his nose and it was all
turned sideways and I mean we were
slipping and sliding in blood and when
they called to fight just cause of blood
I mean I do was tough as [ __ ] he wasn't
quitting and I didn't put him down like
I
had him in Mount you know but he was
sitting there taking hits and he didn't
give a [ __ ] I mean he was tough he was
really tough and the fight wasn't done
but they just talked it cuz of blood
they're just blood everywhere and so
she's seen that and she started pretty
much crying she's like hi I can't
believe it you know and she's like I
don't never want to see this [ __ ] again
ever don't ever show me one of these you
know oh yeah
and does she have other children that do
give us siblings that do it too I got a
sister but she don't she don't do any
roughhouse or anything like no and were
you allowed to wrestle her when you were
younger she used to whup my ass did she
definitely that's a fact
is she tougher than you or no I don't
know she is anymore I think she used to
be but I think she's got soft now oh
yeah it had my sister move out here them
yeah you happily welcome her I know that
we have a lot of fans that send in
questions for you man so I want to get
to some of those and Nick may have a I
do so we try to get you in the week
right after your fight um but you had
finals in college no which I thought was
hilarious you're doing full time
fighting and still in school what are
you studying I'm studying economics
that's my major work I was an economics
major like Ron Paul he's alright I'm a
big Adam Smith and Hayek if you like if
you like Hayek you like Ron yeah yeah
yeah where you like there might be give
or take a few things yeah yeah yeah I
grown Paul they're on the same bus same
page same page yeah oh yeah here's a
question we got from you know the Owen
Bryce what's good this is max here I'm
wondering what is the dumbest reason you
have ever gotten into a fight I won spot
of cake because I thought he cut me in
the lunch line but he did I'm wondering
if you can compete with that cut you in
the lunch line but he didn't you think
you'd have evidence if you did or didn't
man thank you for your question max
that's a good question will you go first
Bryce you to guess man [ __ ] man I have
to say I'd have to say I mean there's a
couple options but I'd had
say definitely the time this kid called
me a [ __ ] and it wasn't you you know
cause you [ __ ] that's fighting words
right there
but anyone get I already knew I was
gonna get in trouble at school my mom
wouldn't happy with me at school and so
I already knew if I fought him right
there I was gonna get kicked out of
school and my mom was gonna be pissed so
I told him I said ma'am I'm gonna see
you later yeah I'll see you yeah I seen
him five years later and I kicked his
ass five-year heat I came up to him I
said get up we're fighting he said what
are we doing what why are you mad at me
you know I said get up we're fighting
yeah I said get up
I said get and he got up and we fought I
remember that five years that's my damn
bro five years I'll wait on a
[ __ ] yeah what if I could get
especially I remember growing up if
somebody called you a [ __ ] that would
just make you so mad yeah yeah I get
it's just like calling somebody a [ __ ]
it's like silence um it doesn't even
matter what it is just the thought
behind the word it's like they they're
not as you're not as good as me or your
dad or whatever you're weak yeah I've
hit dude for calling me a [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] whatever it's just
they're saying something to you they're
acting like they're you know gonna [ __ ]
you up it just pisses you off
yeah do you notice a thing inside of
yourself when you go from being like
pissed - not like not pissed to piss
like do you know is there like a well
definitely because I get the feeling of
wanting to hurting them you know and I
visualize wanting I hurt him and not
really and it sounds [ __ ] up but it's
just the truth man it's yeah God I'm not
a you're a fighter would be [ __ ] up if
he if you were a stenographer you know
if you are like the lady working to tell
me that but you're a fighter that's that
it's in you but every fight though
there's I fought people that I liked you
know and I don't really visualize
hurting them as much but as soon as
somebody says [ __ ] you or your [ __ ] or
I'm gonna knock it like this last dude
he was like [ __ ] you i'ma knock your ass
out
as soon as I hear that it's just like I
want to hurt him
I get angry and I don't even it's almost
like I feel reckless like I don't care
if you [ __ ] me up - I just want to [ __ ]
you up at this point like
get extremely like I want to get my
hands on them I want it like right just
right then and right there I just kind
of feel that the feeling the wanting to
hurt them and I don't feel that about
people until I'm pissed off and like you
know I actually don't want to hurt
nobody but if they pissed me off then
that I do get that feeling then it
changes it changed yeah I definitely can
feel that change and when somebody
pisses me off I do want to hurt her I'm
trying to think man when I was growing
up I know I couldn't fight man I was
like I was just not like I could but I
just wouldn't win so at a certain point
is [ __ ] it you don't know yeah hey you
gotta take ass weapons to give them oh
yeah look dude than I oh so mister
people definitely suck on this one kid
hit me man let's do [ __ ] man he
created a leap year in my brain brothers
gonna knock the guy I think he knocked
half a you know a day out of me man it's
didn't hit me pretty hard but um I'm
kind of think when I actually you know
what happened when I was there was a kid
at school at school when I was in middle
school if you got in a fight with
somebody they made you hug they made you
stand in the hallway at school and put
your arms on each other's shoulders like
that's a bad idea so but but then by the
end you got to do it all day the rest of
the day and by the end of the day you
were friends because you guys had been
right there like you talked it out or
whatever yeah no but yeah this one kid
man he um yeah he was just a big dude oh
we're standing there and I'm like scare
but I'm trying not to be scared you know
that was like one of my big moves and he
was the toughest dude man this kid Brad
Castleman he's a great guy and and we're
friends now but uh somebody next to me
took my arm and pushed it into him right
so I didn't even get to throw a punch
dude you know they just like somebody
standing there watching took my arm and
[ __ ] right into him and I guess that
counts next thing you know man we were
throwing uh we were throwing hands and I
think I got in one decent shot your main
remember me yeah yeah yeah man that's
what I'm talking about you gotta get
that one hit in
and it's funny because I remember
getting the one hit more than I remember
the probably four or five hits it on
yeah yeah exactly and it just you're
right it gave me it did give me some
sense of like oh man I can't even I
could feel the joy that I had in my fist
and in my heart a little more than I
could feel the pain that I had on my
face definitely well that's kind of
interesting really thought about it till
just now
but yeah there's something that's yeah
like I had just been through it you know
like Dustin Poirier always talks about
like you know you go through you go
through these fights and you know win or
lose you are there's something different
about you after you know there's like
you're like battle-tested hell after
that fight after my last fight I got a
drillin burst after the fight I during a
fight i I just was just completely calm
on you know leading up to the fight
everything but afterwards dudes just
like adrenaline went through the roof I
after the fight like cuz I guess I knew
the fight was done and and then my
adrenaline went like crazy
what y'all do to celebrate after I eat
some cheeseburgers and really you know I
don't yeah I don't go crazy I don't
party or nothing like that so I just
hate some cheeseburgers kicked it with
some buddies and then just went to sleep
got about three hours of sleep so and
did you cuz your last fight it was in
Washington DC right mmm was it the first
time you'd ever been up there yep did
you get to do any tourist stuff up there
no when I'm going up there for the fight
I usually don't walk around hardly any
just because it takes strength from your
legs like if you want to walk to the
capital you're probably walking three
four miles by the time it's all said and
done I mean that could deck because
you're already gonna be fatigued from
cutting your weight I mean you could
argue that it that it helps you lose
your weight walking around but I don't
want to lose my weight till an hour to
two hours before the weigh-ins I don't
want to lose it three days before you
know so when I get to the fight I just
chill at the hotel I really don't do
[ __ ] I'll walk to a restaurant that's
closed and that's it just because I
don't want to fatigue my legs by walking
around
because that little bit of walking could
really it could give you soreness you
don't move back when you're supposed to
your feets what keep you safe for me my
feet is what keeps me safe my ability to
move my feet so my legs was one ounce
too tired and there was a big punch
coming and I'm thinking I could just
block this instead of move I need to be
thinking move my feet move my feet the
whole fight saw one of those fresh is a
I'll take ice baths and stuff like that
the week of the fight I take a lot of
ice baths just to try to keep my my legs
fresh that's what keeps me safe from
from getting hit as my feet yeah so its
feet first really for you yeah I like to
uh yeah yeah I like to just and I guess
it's cuz I play basketball for all them
years that's the only thing I could
think of
I got a boxing coach he says now I
didn't from basketball he said you just
given that by God you know but I don't
know what it is but I've got good feet
and and in action when you first start
fighting man it takes you a long time to
find out what you were specifically good
at like you know you know that's funny
man I can relate to that with comedy
mm-hmm like just years of not like
thinking oh maybe I'm this type of guy
you know maybe I'm the you know the
angry guy or maybe I'm the you know the
uh you know the guy that does like a
backflip at the end of his set or
something and you're like [ __ ] I think
that guy maybe I'm the fat black guy
yeah I can see that a little bit yeah
you kind of figure out who you are yeah
figuring out what what your strong suits
are yeah yeah and I mean I'm confident
now dude you know so much more confident
than when I started
and you know I just visualized myself
winning every fight you know I
visualized winning winning winning and I
know how I can do it I know my god-given
abilities and talents and I think I can
beat anybody dude you know and did you
always feel that way or is this because
I I just I love how confidence grows in
someone you know I think it's you know
their times right you go on a stage for
a big show and I would be scared of the
stage I'm thinking about where the
audience is I'm thinking about how I'm
gonna look when I walk out there I'm
thinking about a lot of different things
and then over time like
you know now I have a bigger environment
show and I don't even think about any of
that I just think about well you know
time to go to work you know but it's
interesting how it's slowly a confidence
built after different you know uh over
time yeah yeah same same with me man and
same thing were like full-grown bucks
now yeah we're out there roaming yeah I
just I'm extremely confident you know I
mean and I don't want to come off as
coffee because you know I'm not saying
bet the farm I'm gonna win every fight
yeah but you can bet a couple [ __ ]
you could bet a couple thousand you can
bet a couple of them [ __ ] melon go
hey my coach he 127 hundred Diddy yeah
he bet on you he probably put down at
least 500,000 Wow
I mean we were extremely caught in the
fight win exactly how my coach said he
said cook him through the bone you know
went in there cooked him to the bone he
said he told me for a fight he was like
I really don't see you getting hit and
he cuz he knows I don't give a [ __ ] I'll
get hit yeah I don't give a [ __ ] that's
not gonna determine when I go in there
and [ __ ] die if I have to cuz it's
you know um he said man I just don't
think he's gonna hit you this fight I
really don't I think his saw this dude
he swings heavy and hard but you move
and just like he said he swung hard but
they're slow so I've seen it I move my
feet I think there's people that would
hit me more you know were you surprised
at the speed of the of the punches were
you surprised that a little bit like do
you ever know like is it sometimes
you're like you're expecting you don't
know what it's gonna be like you're like
oh that's it I can deal with that that
must create a lot of confidence in you
when you're out there well win enough
fight first started I remember putting
him on the cage
I remember backing up and this dude you
know he's a striker so right when he put
his back to the cage I thought already
he's a little bit more timid than me mmm
you know you don't mean he can't knock
you out with his back to the cage but I
got him kind of where I want him well
you know so right off the bat I'm
thinking okay you know he's I got him
backed up and then I remember he he
faked and I bet on his faith just
because I come out they're playing it
safe right off the bat I wanna get
knocked out right off the bat you know
yeah so he faked I pulled my feet back
and so if he was good at reading at that
point he knows when I go to throw the
second time he's gonna pull back again
so I just kind of like back step you
know just out of range so and I think he
did I think he made that read he said
okay so he he now measures his
counter-attack and when he threw the
second because the first time he didn't
throw him fate and I move like a foot
back well now he knows okay he's gonna
move about a foot back so this second
time he really does throw and he steps
forward so he progresses progressive oh
I see what you're saying he knows where
you gonna end up yeah and so he knew
right off this uh because you can see I
bid on one of his fakes I backed up
right when he uh he's gonna fake
something here and that's a side kick
that's that range I think he fakes a
right hand maybe but that that when I
get under you see that right hand mm-hmm
um I didn't see what that was and if I
had no [ __ ] clue I just knew he threw
something I don't know if there's a
right or a left but that's just a
testament to my training the stance
yeah and I have a boxing coach who does
a lot of a lot of network with me and
that's a testament to him but uh yeah I
mean I didn't see the punch you know I
just ducked is it scary to start to
realize that uh that you're getting good
at something that you really love I mean
does it make any sense to you I like it
I it makes sense to me I know what
you're saying but I enjoy it I like it
and it's it's really [ __ ] up because
you could really go in there and die and
it could be terrible you go get brain
[ __ ] but I'm already halfway there
ain't much to lose you know so but but
oh no it could be terrible you know but
I have just learned to just enjoy it you
know and it's and I don't know if I
should you know it's kind of [ __ ] up
in the head that I enjoy it but I do I
enjoy it
what's a limited class of people that do
I mean it's it's a such a small amount I
mean it's smaller than I mean it's just
such a small number of people that try
it and then like it
mm-hmm you know I don't even know what
you were compared to we got a question
right here from some guy who looks
semi-nude right here
I also gotta say I won 200 on the under
yeah I've actually seen Matt sales
weirdly fight before he's in the UFC
like in person three times it just
randomly happens so I didn't want to bet
against him I liked you both but I took
the under and good kid out
well he's a good striker man yeah did
you meet him when you went down to
Alliance cuz he's that he's with
Dominick Cruz right he definitely is you
know I don't know if I did or not it was
so many years ago and I've been hit so
many times I really can't remember I'm
sure he was there at the very least you
know but he's a good striker I didn't
you know I would have engaged him on the
feet but I wanted I knew he didn't want
to be on the ground so that's where I
want to go mm-hmm
here we go I got a question for Brice
Mitchell if you could apply your scrotum
angulation to any other fighter on the
UFC roster would it be Gang Gang [ __ ]
buzz buzz gang and I think he's talking
with that drill other than us yeah
that's your next finishing move that
shit'll finished somebody else promise
me I don't say and you put it how big
was that bit you put in your bag for
about six inches long you want to get
people up to speed
yeah sorry for people aren't up to speed
you tell them Bryce well I was building
a roof over my camper a metal roof with
a wood frame oh yeah it's like a story
out of the Bible I mean definitely a
deleted chapter so I'm up there building
that wood frame I got my drill in my
hands and I'm holding up a board to size
it up to find out where this boards
gonna go and then I you know decided I
need two hands to hold this board
properly to make sure it's level cuz I'm
just eyeballing it I'm not even using a
level it don't have to be perfect you
know building a Sistine Chapel and
building a [ __ ] roof over a trailer
so yeah you know I'm just eyeballing I'm
looking at it and I put the drill in my
pants and the sumbitch goes off
and man it was terrible I mean all the
ladder
I was on the ladder I was on a ladder 20
foot up in the air about a fell out of
dive and first I thought it ripped my
Weiner off and so I mean I really did I
really I mean it got were you afraid to
open your pain yeah yeah I always be - I
was afraid then I knew I had to like I
wasn't from the devastation yeah I was
thinking man if this written my wiener
off I'm just gonna just die it's okay
you know it's whatever you've lived a
good a good life you know but I know how
to take your own life that there and
bled out might not have took myself the
hostage but I opened my pants and I
remember I remember seeing my nuts
wrapped up and there was blood and semen
leaked in and there was like I could see
a testicle wrapped up but I was so happy
I mean it was just like the life was
just right back in me does he had a
chance because I Weiner was there and my
wiener was there when I said I was like
thank God when you see that intact
[ __ ] penis and [ __ ] boost your
spirit yeah if I take mine out right now
and look at it I'll feel better that's
what I'm saying and so I'm sitting there
and I'm just like okay well you know I'm
still a shitty situation because you
because it went through your pants right
oh no you put it in your hand yes that's
right yeah as a tool bill yeah I didn't
have a tool belt mm-hmm that's why I
[ __ ] up and so then you drove that's
such a risky it's bad bad business man I
didn't put this I didn't put the safety
on bro if somebody even just takes a
[ __ ] bro it's like if you if you sit
naked somewhere like in your apartment
or house and you put a [ __ ] pair of
scissors open them up and then set them
by your penis dude you will flip the fan
yeah yeah and imagine I'm so stupid I'll
put a damn live drill me I saw dams but
I'm telling you I've been hit too many
times and so I'm trying I'm trying to
get this drill out and I tug on it and
it ain't going like it's it's all
entangled up in there yeah and there's a
lot in there people don't realize that
that's I'm saying a picture of that
there's fluids they got the big
Louise and stuff it's like this weird
mucus slime [ __ ] comes out you're nuts
yeah that's your family but it supposed
to be here yeah yeah but that's your
genetics lot rolling out there the eggs
brother yeah yeah look at that nut that
thing is a real artistic [ __ ] little
deal and it actually had my big nut to
is my left nut oh the low one my left my
left nuts way bigger and it was it was
wrapped up and so I was like no do not
debate not the big nut you know yeah you
got a big one you should have been in
chorus that's what these two tell us in
school they tell us look at your nuts if
you got a big one you supposed to be in
chorus and they even in that picture
left one sitting lowers that's how many
well they can't be a picture of my it
could be a drawing I don't know it
doesn't have any drills in it and so I
reversed this drill right and I reverse
it put in reversing the testicle unwinds
and I'm just sitting there I throw the
drill down I got a big old gaping hole
in my nuts I'm leaking out a lot of
blood she strove to the hospital would
you wrap around him you wrap anything
round me just hold it I just held him
yeah I just held him one hand and then
was driving with the other and then when
I got to the hospital the nerd like the
nurses was out there talking [ __ ] that's
what made me man I could hear him I
didn't want to make a scene because I
thought they literally might kick me out
of the hospital I wanted to be like hey
I can hear you [ __ ]
you know what I mean she's making a
saying this guy's [ __ ] killed us yes
yeah they're like this guy's an idiot
yeah they're literally saying it there I
can hear like three nurses out there he
did what yeah he drilled his nuts up
what an idiot
he's an idiot you know I'm just sitting
here I'm just so mad I'm just trying to
relax because I already know if I go
full and [ __ ] you you know they're gonna
kick me out of the hospital with these
split up nuts and I'm gonna have to go
to Little Rock with half a nut sewn up
you know Johnny knows that they probably
not gonna be able to figure out over
there that's what I'm saying you could
have been traveling all across the south
yeah with this bad bag and I had
I just sit there and take one on chin
and everything everything get fixed up
so yeah I'm really lucky you know I
probably should have died dang man and
have you do you uh you don't have any
children of your own no no sir yeah
hopefully not yeah and do you think
about it it's not you think about yet I
mean if I don't want one you know I
really don't but yeah uh maybe in the
future maybe I'm so busy right now I
wanna I'd like to give devote all my
time and you know I'm saying to my child
but right now it's like I'd have to put
all my career like I couldn't go to LA
or if I did then I wouldn't be getting
see my kids for three days yeah I'd be
worried about that the whole time so I
really don't want the responsibilities
yeah not everyone is a fighter but
sometimes you want to dress up like a
job that you could have or you might
have the job I'm talking about nursing
doctoring dentists ting or people that
work in medicine and healthcare and
there's a company called FIGS
it's an amazing company it's making
scrubs stylish and functional for the
people who deserve it most
for years nurses and dentists and
doctors were forced to wear scratchy
ill-fitting scrubs almost burlap ooh but
figs scrubs are infused with anti
microbial properties to control odors
they're ridiculously soft moisture
wicking and features four-way stretch
figs gives back as well every time you
shop at figs they give scrubs to
healthcare providers in need around the
world through their threads for threads
initiative show how much you care at the
end of the year with figs this holiday
season figs is going to make that easy
by providing you with 15% off your first
purchase by using our code Theo get
ready to love your scrubs head to where
figs calm and enter our code th EO at
checkout my sister's getting figs she
already knows it I've said it before and
here's the crazy part
I forgot to ask her what size so I'm
really interested to see if they fit
she is a nurse in Baton Rouge and I'm
very proud of her that's right figs this
past weekend is brought to you by
Skillshare not everybody can fight or a
sore twister not everybody could wring
their neighbors neck if they want to
over a hay issue but Skillshare is an
online learning community for creators
with more than 25,000 classes and design
business and more you'll discover
countless ways to fuel your curiosity
they have classes and social media
marketing mobile photography creative
writing and even illustration whether
you're looking to discover a new passion
start a side hustle or gain professional
skills Skillshare is there to keep you
learning thriving and reaching those new
goals are you a freelancer try
bookkeeping for freelancers how to
handle your finances it's funny because
I need to hire someone to do that right
now
join the mains of students already
learning on Skillshare today with a
special offer just for our listeners get
two months of Skillshare for free that's
right Skillshare is offering tpw
listeners two months of unlimited access
to over 25,000 classes for free go to
Skillshare comm slash Theo von again go
to Skillshare comm slash Theo von to
start your two months now that's skill
shared comm slash Theo von and now back
to the episode did you finish the roof
hell yeah brother that roof is done is
it I was gonna get the roof done or die
trying
now is it a roof one of those ones
that's kind of a free-standing roof
that's separate from the trailer that's
what my sister had yeah yeah let me show
you picture it's a lean style and the
reason I did that it's cuz I want to put
its its it's not the a-frame it's like
one high side one low side I'm gonna put
solar panels on one side of it and I
face that side towards the Sun oh wow so
oh [ __ ] my phone's off I'll turn I'll
show you a picture of I'm proud of it
and what animals do you guys have living
over there at your house you have any
pet to your own you have any pets yeah
we got two dogs
oh yeah we're work once this uh once I
get all the farm and equipment and
everything I'm gonna get chickens first
yeah
I'm gonna get cattle and I'm gonna get a
milk cow when I get a milk cow imma get
hogs because a milk cow it can produce
five gallons a day and I mean we won't
even need but two gallons a week you
give three gallons at hogs everyday Wow
yeah into the pub yeah so when I get a
milk cow now milk cows more
responsibility than regular cattle so
I'm gonna we gotta walk them everything
well you gotta milk them every day they
dry up oh yeah and isn't that crazy if
you don't milk them they dry up mm-hmm
really interesting mm-hmm yeah one time
I was somewhere dude doing something we
were looking for mushrooms and this man
had up dairy and he ended up letting us
drink right out of the pail after the
pink am i right out two teeth I didn't
get anything up the team I mean I'm
gonna go to heaven right that's right
there yeah I do but the Lord catches you
sucking on an animal brah yeah I had to
figure it out first I think I figured it
out first
I ain't messed up about it man
let's let's get another call from one of
our listeners man I gotta show you this
roof brother oh yeah I want to see it
what I feel what up Bryce it's your boy
Alejandro coming at you guys from
Chicago my questions for Bryce tune into
that season of The Ultimate Fighter you
are on obviously a bunch of undefeated
fighters I'm just wondering how you took
that first loss even though it's not on
your record how'd you mentally deal with
that being able to come back with that
same mentality of a undefeated fighter
thank you guys you guys are the best
gang gang and Bryce Reebok better get
you them damn camo shorts
hell yeah my brother they way it's just
gonna take time I like it they're gonna
fold before our fold I like your
attitude bro uh here's that little roof
though you gotta check this [ __ ] out
oh man that's beautiful dude I'm not an
engineer you know I'm just I just bought
some wood and some metal start putting
[ __ ] together man that's good man you
guys right there by the power lines too
huh
well I had to put that in that runs to
the road I put that that line in
Oh awesome man and is that a chicken
coop in the back to doghouse oh it's up
on stilts oh yeah the Coyotes Oh a lot
of coyotes out there dem coyotes can't
walk up there there - maybe if they were
starving to death they would but they
just did a great job man thank you thank
you very much
alejandro my brother so how I do with my
with that loss on the show man it's just
like every other loss you know that
ain't the first time I've had my ass
whooped my when nobody was looking my
neighbor Jimmy knocked me out in the
front yard you know I guess that it
would be with them haymakers hey Jimmy
you've got a haymaker let me tell you
Jimmy knock your ass out with that -
Jimmy hits harder [ __ ] and and don't
[ __ ] Jimmy sister I didn't do it
somebody I've seen so many sister no
that's not good
you're not learn if you ain't the one
doing it if you watch him from the
window that still counts bro when Jimmy
was just training that's when he knocked
me out was was in training but that was
way back in day but you know ever since
I was a little kid I've been getting my
ass whupped it doesn't fit you another
fit it's not there's no there must not
to be a fear of that you're not afraid
of now as I always say I'm more when I
talk about what could go bad in a fight
I'm always more worried about us me
doing something and but not performing
to the best of my ability it's not the
fact that you know do could bust you up
break your nose all that [ __ ] you know
that that sucks well but what really
would get me as if I did something
embarrassed if I went in there and just
brought shame to my family that's
something I couldn't live with you know
I go in there to fight bring honor my
family anybody my family say wow you
know win or lose that that the kids are
[ __ ] fighter he thought he did his job
that's your job it's going in fights the
best your ability not to win it's just
to give it every damn thing you got and
but yeah that wasn't my first loss on
the the Ultimate Fighter but I'd say
just dealing with losses in general man
you just you know it's it's shitty and
life is a [ __ ] man
you're just gonna have to hike it yeah
it's
life you know I'm saying and I got
people that what I visualize is is me
providing for the people that I love you
know I'm saying that's what my ultimate
goal in this sport is and that's the
only reason I'm doing it it's because I
think the people I love are gonna live
better lives well now I know they are
and if I have to take if I have to walk
through losses ass-kickings
embarrassment people talking [ __ ] to me
on twatter can't even have an Instagram
and a Twitter and a Facebook no more
because people talk [ __ ] to me I can't
handle it when people talk [ __ ] to me
like I said I visualize hurting them and
well yeah you can't have deep in that
stuff like I had to delete my Twitter my
Instagram Instagram was cuz of squirrel
pictures they started taking down my
squirrel picture oh yeah I know so I
know why is that so Instagram took it
down just because you put it up as a
meat as a yeah as a edible yeah and it's
like dude they say cruelty to animals
yeah that's [ __ ] insane if you will
[ __ ] if you need animal if you're eating
the animal to live or your he's the
animal that's what I'm saying and you
know people post pictures of
cheeseburgers yeah and steaks and all
this [ __ ] guess what you know I don't
care what kind of world you live in and
[ __ ] fantasy world they [ __ ]
killed a cow to get that steak get that
burger not only did they kill it I
killed them squirrels in about two
seconds and they lived a natural life
and how do you kill him rear naked choke
what do you do with well cuz the deer I
drew naked real small [ __ ] Omar him
man
what last deer I killed our rear naked
choke it man yeah I didn't I didn't even
shoot it I mean no bullsh and did you
sneak up on it
yeah it was a doe he was sleeping I
caught it was a about a three-hour
ordeal
you know I sitting up in a deer stand I
called this doe and everybody says that
though was [ __ ] or had some CWD I'm
telling you it's perfectly healthy doe I
just got a test you know I just I waited
I was patient and I got really lucky it
wasn't just so much skill it was a lot
of look mmm but what happened is I was
calling in this doe and lays down in
front of me goes to sleep and I shoot at
it with my crossbow and I missed and it
only had one bolt and it didn't it
didn't move it well it got up and
looked around and like looked it but
them crossbows it's not like a gun it
just sounds like a branch breaking you
know so it got up and it looked around
and went right back to sleep
lazy huh yeah lazy man Sunday or my day
off dude it's just my lucky day man I
was I was just meant to get that deer
I'm telling you because I just had the
feeling I was like I visualize getting
it because it was like I said I called
it in for three hours and I really had
to piss and I really had there was this
little protein cookie sitting right by
me in the deer stand I knew I wanted to
take a piss and I want to eat that
cookie yeah I was like man if you piss
that deers gonna smell it if you reach
for that cookie the wrapper is gonna
make a noise I was like you can just saw
three hours I'm sitting there just
staring at this deer not moving it's
cold
I finally shoot and I miss and dude is
most disappointed feeling at me and I
instantly thought man this deers gonna
get away I didn't get no meat on my
table and when it went back to sleep
then how did you make that move I
thought well I'm gonna try some crazy
[ __ ] and and I started making my way
down down to the deer I start making my
way down a deer stand
tiptoe you rollerblade that's the
definition of tiptoe I'm walking like
ambrosia well yeah yeah well I I get
halfway down a deer stand I start
thinking why don't I just grab my
hatchet cuz I could chop it by Mauri
halfway down your stance so you don't
back too late yeah and then I start
thinking you know what I'm better with
my bare hands because that's what I do
for a living no no so I started thinking
okay I'm gonna get this dough and
there's a dead tree pointing at it so
that did is prob about 35 yards away 40
yards away when I started there's a dead
tree pointing at it hmm
so I walked the whole link to that dead
tree you know that nothing no noise at
all right real quiet real couldn't hear
me yeah I mean nothing could hear me so
now I'm up close to it when I got to the
end of that dead tree I'm like from here
to that that window away from it I'm
thinking I'm gonna get this [ __ ] deer
there's no I take my gloves off go ahead
on big thick gloves but when you get
that close you can't you gotta you're
gonna have to have straight on the hand
that's when the reality set in it's like
I'm not just trying to do this [ __ ] I'm
about to get my hands on it so I take my
gloves off you can't go up they're all
[ __ ] just soft mitt no you know you
want to grip yeah you know
I take my gloves off I might do this
shit's getting real that's when my
adrenaline was just like it felt like a
fight like a little and he's still
asleep
he said yeah she it's a she yeah yeah
she's sleeping completely change your
vibe any that it's a man or a woman
you're about to attack no I saw it's on
me
I wouldn't attack a small one but just
because it's a it has a potential to
grow bigger
so you harvest that meat later oh I see
what you're saying I have no you know
you're killing something either way
whether it's a male or female and I
don't I'm not even into the the trophy
hunt and I really don't care if it's the
biggest buck in the world if somebody
asks would you rather have the biggest
buck ever did some 12 pointer or you
know three doves yeah I'll take three
doe there's more meat you know I'm
really just there for the meat and so
then I it was a wet day it rained all
day before and so if you're especially
if you're squirrel hunting or something
that's the best best time to do it is
when it's damp outside them leaves don't
crunch you know so then it fell asleep
like I said it was meant to be it wasn't
just because of my skill it was God was
giving that [ __ ] to me he wasn't he
wanted that that food on table he wanted
me to get to have that experience and
the the deer fell asleep on a game trail
so fell asleep on a on a damp day on a
game trail and on the game trail that's
where all these other deer were walking
so they've already crunched the leaves
for me so it's like there's hardly any
leaves there the few leaves that there
are it's wet this deer cannot hear me
it's a layup
this is this is a [ __ ] setup you know
I'm saying this deer - shut up Chris
Hanson might pop out from one of these
they're like oh well dude I get up there
on the deer I mean he didn't I didn't
make a noise man it was perfect
conditions and then uh I text my coach I
had my phone in my pocket I straddled
the deer when I straddled the deer
that's when I text my coach and it's
still asleep still sleep and your text
I'm texting I'm texting and the only
reason I was texting my coaches because
I really thought that doe might get up
and what my ass is about 100 something
100-plus pounds oh is those [ __ ] are
strong men
and you can close your post mate SAP at
that point because you're mucking about
- about to eat yeah well I texted my
coach I texted him help help and run and
because I didn't want to explain to him
hey I'm about to choke out a deer like
he would be like yeah it's a lot it's a
lot so I never deer emoji I don't know
if they have it they do they do they do
well I just text them help help run
because I want him thinking I'm about to
die right so he gets there quickly as
possible so right after I sent a text he
said okay and [ __ ] I hopped on that deer
I couldn't get my right hand in because
the way it was laying it's laying on its
right side so I choked it with my my
weaker arm with with choking I put my
left arm on it and wrapped my ankles you
know did a did the standard little ankle
ankle lock you know I couldn't do a body
triangle so I just crossed my ankles and
squeezed every little [ __ ] just squeezed
it for about five minutes to my coach
got there and did it feel good or bad
well the thing was kicking so hard that
I thought it was alive when he got there
and I thought that the [ __ ] was gonna
get away you know I really did I mean it
was just composing and twitching so hard
I couldn't I couldn't control its back
legs at all I had his front legs pretty
good with my legs around him and my
knees was pensioned so its front legs I
felt good about and you know I had it by
the head put them back legs dude they're
just kicking up dirt just panicking just
kickin up mud flying yeah like a [ __ ]
angry baseball coach yeah and and so
coach comes over and he's like what are
you doing he says what are you doing
and I already know what he's thinking in
his head so I didn't even try to I said
I didn't [ __ ] shoot it because he I
already know anything she's shot over
here this [ __ ] a running around
I didn't [ __ ] shoot it and he goes
what I said I swear to God I didn't
shoot it I swear to God he said you're
kidding
I said I swear to God stab this
[ __ ] he's gonna get away because
I my arm was cramping I mean I was
squeezing it for five minutes and this
thing is just kicking as hard as it was
when I first did n't slow down it was
just not a bit not a [ __ ] and you had
to expect it was gonna start to slow
down yeah it didn't so I don't know
where its windpipe is or anything
okay the same saying that's where you're
all at this I'm on it yeah I'm on it
throw it I mean I'm on it just I mean
I've finished most my fights for rear
naked choke so you know if there's one
thing I can finish it's that damn rear
naked choke and I'm doing it just like I
should but I'm just like [ __ ] this thing
is tough as [ __ ] you can't choke a deer
you know and he said what do you want me
do you never see deers choking each
other yeah
and so I'm like you know stab stab him
quick stab her stabber
and he said well he said I don't got my
knife I said run to Deer saying get my
hatchet cuz my hatchet was in Deer
saying the one that I forgot so he runs
up there runs back and he finally goes
to chop its neck and when I let go that
deer was dead because the head went limp
and even though the body was twitching
the head went completely limp and it was
like
you know made like a moan that started
out high but then ended up it's like you
know like that was its last bit of air
coming out of the lungs so I already
knew that the den he chopped its neck
anyways just to make sure that it was
dead but uh yeah but while I was choking
out I really thought the deer was alive
I didn't know till I let go that I
already killed it damn so he could have
been dead that whole time he probably
probably was after about two minutes
that's almost like a rodeo a little bit
of doing
Wow I pay money to see that riding
bareback dead deer ride and I [ __ ] this
[ __ ] was wild but I know people are
gonna be hating on me these animal
cruelty people hey that's the best way
if you're a deer you you want me to
choke you to death every time cuz let me
tell you what these deer they die no
matter what no matter if I choke them or
coyote them or they get old and and you
know hit by car they're gonna die and
that's the most painless way to die that
deer is probably unconscious trust me
I've been choked out a lot okay that
deer is probably unconscious in about
seven seconds and it was waking up from
a nap can you imagine waking up from a
nap and then just basically going right
back to I mean you're not even gonna
know what's going on
you barely awake you're like what was
that you're going to heaven yeah and I
mean I set there man and I said God
wanted me to have that meat I said there
I still lay up man that's what I'm
saying man hey God put that deer there
for me I said a prayer I was like I said
thank you for right before I took a shot
in my head I said God thank you for
giving us meat to me my family needs it
I'm gonna you know put it towards me to
kiss the girl we're all gonna eat good
off this deer thank you so much I'm so
grateful I take the shot miss mm-hmm guy
said you gonna have to work harder net
yeah I ain't easy out here but yeah man
that's a beautiful story dude but um you
know that that's the most painless way
to go out getting choked out think about
a deer get shot in the ass all the time
or the gut oh yeah and they run away
they never get found they died three
hours later they slowly bleed to death I
mean we're in net get hit by a Volvo get
hit
fan imagine getting hit by a [ __ ] fan
yeah not even an SUV and these [ __ ]
I don't even keep the meat man yeah
they'll drive off and the deer just
sitting there moaning crying it's like
any time I see a deer on a side road if
it's still alive I'm cutting the throat
and putting it in a trunk you know these
people just drive off and leave ya then
a lot of areas people want to say like
yeah I agree
don't choke a deer out in the [ __ ]
middle of Beverly Hills right I get it I
understand how those people think that
way but in rural Arkansas or in a place
where people eat meat use it all the
time you know man it's just part of life
too
I'm not opposed to choking one out in a
park yeah now here we said Beverly Park
yeah Barry Park dude I'm trying to think
what you could catch around here you
could probably shoot some antique for
some of those people speaking of here we
have a question right here that came in
but speaking of antifa I want to ask
this your you said you don't really go
on the social media but I'm wondering if
your manager filled you in like what
kind of response you got after Trump
quote tweeted you yeah that's all oh
yeah it's a wild try you got a coach of
you from the president that's amazing
man it's so wild huh and like I said my
mom she don't support my MMA career at
all she's always saying I want you to
quit I want this to be the last one I
want you to do this again but man when
she found out Donald Trump tweeted me
she called and she said oh my god she
was just screaming she said ah Donald
Trump I mean she she likes Donald Trump
a lot excited she was super excited I
mean that's probably most proud of me
she's ever been at the game what's funny
is uh my PAP I love my pet ball very
much and this your grandfather yes sir
yes sir he's still alive after my last
fight he said uh he said man I was you
did good and you know I'm just telling
my love him and tell him thanks and
everything and
I said you see the governor text me he
said the president texture I said now
the president ain't texted me yet I said
that might be a while
next fight the president lesson you know
messages I mean I said wow that's
interesting that's amazing it is funny
as long as you can almost feel stuff
like that you can feel sometimes certain
things gonna happen in your life a
little bit like sometimes you get a
little bit of a premonition in a weird
way yeah yeah I like that word
premonition that's that's I'm gonna
start using that word that's what I get
I get premonitions and stuff yeah
and it's a real man those are really
really real like I remember getting one
of uh I remember like they have an actor
that hit me up about being in a movie uh
earlier this year and a couple of weeks
before I've been looking on Instagram
and it seemed that he liked something
I'm on mm-hm and I'll be like man it
would be so wild if he hit me up and
asked me about being in a film mm be so
interesting mm-hm and then two weeks
later it happened you know it's just I
mean it's just I mean I don't have any
ego in it it's just interesting how
those premonitions can be real sometimes
people just shake them off like it's
nothing I liked I used to shake a mommy
- I used to shake them off bro and now I
look at him like that yeah I know
exactly what you're talking about I feel
the same way about man something it's
almost strange and weird you know but
yeah I like those - yeah it's even more
wild he asked you and you said no yeah
yeah and here's the craziest part about
the movie I'm walking down the street I
so I got into this film and then I
backed out of it it was just too much of
a time commitment yeah I'm walking down
the street the other night and I see a
guy who's in the movie and I said how's
it going he's like man I'm just bummed I
have to fly back out tomorrow we still
gotta shoot scenes I gotta fly back out
in two weeks you didn't want to be in
you right and man at that one moment I
was like oh I made the right choice for
myself you know even though I think
either choice would have been okay but I
was like oh uh I trusted whatever
instinct was in me I trusted it hmm you
know did you always feel like because I
know coming from like a humble beginning
and that sort of place and coming from
you know you know just to come from kind
of aikka
I don't want to say redneck I don't
believe in a lot of that kind of stuff
but I think of like rural you know
coming from a more simpler place do you
ever feel like you were destined for
something bigger but did you ever
honestly feel like that for yourself
because some people never think that you
know or never have that desire
did you that's a better word that never
some people never have that desire for
something bigger or more grandiose kind
of did you ever think that or is this
all this being kind of like as your
platform is growing and you know your
name in your sport is it just been kind
of a surprise I think that uh what
you've just described there I've heard
people that I trained with because you
know I've been talking about wanting to
be in the UFC for over ten years now
since I mean I was its didn't you know
it's one overnight this is a long time
ago when you first start everybody
thinks that's impossible you know and
I've heard people in the gym that I
trained with that are good people
more talented than myself you know I
don't have a lot of talent you know I
[ __ ] work hard I'm tough as [ __ ] and
I'm not scared of nobody
you know and that's oh well then I don't
have that did I think I have worked hard
though and man the guys in the gym yeah
their mortality you say it and yeah the
guy in a gym you know and this was
probably ten more than 10 years ago
dudes said man I said man can't you wait
till we get to UFC and they're gonna be
[ __ ] badass and he said and we're
just never gonna make it from this
little town that's what he said and so
my people do think about like stuff like
that has never stopped me ever you know
it's just not part of your brain it's
not part of how your brain does it no
and I think it adds coolness to a story
too you know doing something from
somewhere that a lot of other people
aren't doing you know it just it makes
me unique and not just my my
personality or whatever where I'm from
it makes my fighting style unique I'm
doing some [ __ ] that's the you know I
mean I'm doing [ __ ] that you don't see
it it's some of these other gems man
where you got fifty MMA fighters I mean
I'm doing some top-secret [ __ ] yeah and
do you love that a little bit I mean do
you uh do you start to think like what
else can I do that is unique you know
because things always evolve you know
like I remember people started dribbling
the basketball like the batter like
every little thing in sports things
always evolve some someone finds a new
way of doing it a little bit of a new
way or a new look or a new vibe really
mm-hmm
and is that something you start to feel
a little bit like man I wouldn't have a
mad if you told me when I started that I
would have evolved as much as and really
nobody knows how much I've evolved as a
fighter besides myself right because now
I know what I'm capable of and I know
where I started nobody else does they
just see from the outside but I'm
telling you man I would have never
imagined there was so many inch and it's
like everyday you learn you work
something new and you're always I'm
always trying to learn something new I
just wouldn't have imagined that it
would it'll probably be like that till
I'll retire and then after I retire I'll
just train for fun and I'll probably be
that old dude that still saved up a
couple ass weapons and I have some new
moves to try out on some young punk yeah
just talking some [ __ ] to me take
somebody [ __ ] down over at Walley
world Walmart or some [ __ ] Walmart
dude they should make in some people man
they had this one family I know they
used to tie a couple carts together you
know when they bring the carts in
they'll push them all in well this
family they would like they would talk a
couple carts in the front where it
wouldn't come all the way back and they
just push like a train and just load
them all that's five or six kids hanging
off kid between the tits what anybody's
got just one warm ass kid some real
premature I think that kid I think he
was real pretty mature he's
he's just still be on the inside but
he's on the outside she's got him just
bacon right between him [ __ ] front
breads man we got a question that came
in right here we didn't get to it let's
go hey guys this is Grace from Minnesota
and my question for you is what's the
best compliment so you've ever received
and who was it from
and my second question is you still have
your underwear from the Ultimate Fighter
gang man look I had to think about this
one because there is a compliment that I
just can't remember it but I remember
getting that compliment and thinking
that might be the greatest thing
somebody's ever said to me
mmm just can't remember what the [ __ ]
I've been hit to me damn time but could
you ever remembered before you were hit
I wonder oh okay hey you hear this here
there's somebody in the gym and this
might not this is the best thing that I
can think of right off the bat somebody
came up to the gym after my fight and
they said they they were all pumped up
they're like we doing twisters tonight
because I teach a jujitsu class I say
hell yeah we're doing twisters tonight
it was right after I got that twister so
everybody's won cuz if you show a
twister but you never done one in a
competition um I said oh this is some
[ __ ] [ __ ] is this and I know it
works cuz I do it all time but after my
fight now other people can say okay it
really does work this kids not on some
crazy [ __ ]
yeah well learn the twister from him and
yeah this woman she come up to me and
she said I really like your coaching she
said you were born to do this
Wow yeah even as a coach huh mm-hmm
that's really she was talking about my
coaching that's a compliment huh yeah
that's probably one of the greatest
compliment somebody ever told me and
what that's more than just saying you're
a good coach yeah that's what made you
feel good about it
just on the inside man just made me feel
like I have a purpose you know yeah and
I mean that's the ultimate goal I guess
of a coach is to make you know feel like
you have a purpose like you're helping
these people yeah uh is it important for
you to help other people hell yeah dude
I want to train some ninjas man hell
yeah I'm with somebody [ __ ] someone
inches in the Walmart parking lot man I
want them twisting them up in a pretzel
you know hey Eddie's are you gonna open
up a new head and do something and I
take it I take it super serious trying
to coach the technique just down into
the little nitty gritty details don't
watch your hands this way do it this way
or vice versa you know just and I forgot
where I was going with that yeah I take
it serious you know I really want to do
the best that I can
being a coach yeah it's nice man it's
nice to have appreciation what you do I
wonder sometimes if I would ever teach
comedy I don't think I would I think
it's such an individual type of thing
where it's just your own personality and
stuff I don't think there's anything
people always ask me like how do I get
in to comment I get you know a lot of
people that send that in and and I'm
grateful for people asking me but it's
really just with that it's just practice
you know there's not really a technique
you can learn from anyone else you know
so in that sense I can't relate to some
of that but what did you say a great
compliment um somebody told me one time
this girl said what I like about your
comedy is for smart people and dumb
people
she said yeah and that made me feel
pretty good I think hell yeah cuz I
never knew which one I was anyway I
think I made me feel pretty good we got
a mix of both yeah okay yeah where I
grew up man it was embarrassing to be
smart if you were smart yeah do you
remember anything like that like if
somebody was [ __ ] smart dude look at
this [ __ ]
I mean they definitely stand out I would
say we made fun of them but you know
smart people did not want anything to do
with [ __ ] the alphabet more [ __ ]
ideas bruh I'm trying to tell my kid
what an idea was yeah oh my dude is like
when something comes into your head that
you don't really know he's like what's
what he talking about he goes ah man you
missed me with all of that [ __ ] you
never had
she was uh she's asking about those
boxers too and about them boxers I have
at least like 10 packs of them left yeah
because that's what that was a main
prize the main thing you took yeah on
the show they let you request stuff and
so that's all our request was box person
so I got 10 packs of boxers there I mean
I'm gonna have boxers from that show for
the next probably 10 years at least amen
and we're gonna [ __ ] we're gonna keep
you good we're here we're gonna make you
keep and if she was talking about the
bloody ones I don't know if she was
talking about the book because that's
the one that I ripped my nuts up in huh
and the boxers are fine they just had
blood all over them but uh we were gonna
frame them put them in a frame and you
know just tell people a story oh I
thought you meant use them in a crime
[ __ ] lame bio murder
[Laughter]
yeah we started smelling so bad oh they
start smelling justice god-awful just
blood and semen smells right [ __ ] that
man we just power wash them and now I
wear hell yeah that's a good pair I mean
they didn't get ripped I mean that's
solid material yeah that's pressure
washing do you ever get one of those
pressure washers on hose the ones you
use at home those things are [ __ ]
nice no they're strong as [ __ ] some of
them are real strong if you get the
industrial and the one that have like
the gas powered dude that thing almost
cut your skin open so you know they cook
like machines that cut through metal
that's maybe they use lasers and some of
them but a lot of them just use water
yeah cut through metal
it's crazy on yeah I mean you really
some of them you I've heard of sand or
something sand there's lasers but water
will cut right through metal if it comes
out with enough pressure
it's wild huh mm-hmm dude lasers are
wild Brian when I was growing up do you
tell people what is the thing Oh
lasers bro if you wanted [ __ ] to sell
something to somebody they'd be like
dude you want to buy this hat the bike
nah don't want to bike dog it's got
lasers on them like a horn okay dude
[ __ ] rural people love lasers man and
I think that as far secret weapons go
and [ __ ]
I definitely think the government's got
some badass lasers I think we could melt
some other [ __ ] if we want it to
that's one thing I do believe in secret
weapons as far as they go I think we got
some type of ghetto invisibility type
thing yeah and I think it's boot then I
will say the invisibility I bet is
[ __ ] bootleg like you just kind of
began to choose yeah but you can't see
their shoes you can still like yeah
you're there Keys jingling but it's good
enough yeah I think we got invisibility
it just is kind of shaky right now we do
kind of show up around the side like
[ __ ] I guarantee you we got some
lasers that could melt a [ __ ]
guaranteed I believe that man up you
know they have a laser we look at this
stuff that can hear through walls you
know that so they could put a laser on
your house and hear what you're saying
mmm that's crazy man let's see what kind
of secret weapons they got in it can you
google secret weapons for people if they
come up on Google I think that's a
failure of a secret weapon dude they
used to have look they have a museum in
Philadelphia where you can go and they
have all the spy stuff that they ever
use your spies like they have like a
little camera that like a bird would
wear and he'll fly out and see stuff is
that in DC or Phillip you said
Philadelphia how could they have it in
DC too close to Philadelphia to DC I
think it's probably about a three-hour
drive well my buddy he was telling me
because I'm when I was up in DC he's uh
he's in all [ __ ] like that he said man
you got to go to the Spy Museum oh wow
so either they have one in DC or he was
mistaken about the one in Philadelphia
it could be some of them travel
different spots I think like they'll do
like yeah couple months here because it
was not a whole museum I will say this
it was just an exhibit at a museum
mm-hmm
ten'll s secret weapons right there
number ten laser look that's the first
one on the list I can tell you right now
that's that's what I said that's number
one on the list everybody knows when you
start going down that list it's gonna
get more top secret yeah we're talking
about some butt bombs man you know some
dirty dirty [ __ ] you don't
[ __ ] laser acoustic devices that's it
that's long rat ain't gonna work on me
man look these ears shaking a horse
would on the edges then would greatest
area voice a man that's say that
acoustic [ __ ] ain't gonna work on me
buddy
now harp do you know about that harp
stuff I'm supposed to control the
weather with I believe it
I believe they are controlling the
weather and [ __ ] with it man I wouldn't
be shocked dude I don't know about all
the store stuff I don't know what that
is
what is this flying aircraft carriers in
the United States began exploring the
tactical potential of airborne aircraft
carriers that be sick you got planes
flying out of a plane W dope yeah the
future brought subliminal messages let's
go back to that that's been going on
that's been going on subliminal messages
used extensively in advertising dude
that [ __ ] happens all the time yeah
that's it that's not even no secret
that's just stuff that's a thing there
definitely oh I'll be thinking about
like some chicks or something dude I'll
walk outside three chicks will walk by
and I'd be like thinking about chicks
that's crazy man any other questions
Nick I just had one
so you just signed with UFC you had
fights left when you signed did they
like Reese on you did you think about
like waiting it out and like cuz like
PFL they got their tournament for a
million dollars Rory MacDonald just
signed with them did you ever think of
that as a thing because like I think you
could beat Lance Palmer yeah man that
pfl man I was in I was signed to wsof
when I went bankrupt and turned into PS
yeah so but my and I'm not here to put
nobody on blast everything was fine and
worked out but my world series of
fighting contract was going terrible man
they they didn't find me the number
fights that they said that they would
and they would only like Bellator
offered me before I signed USC Bellator
offered and wsof wouldn't let me fight
for Bellator so it's like I missed a
Bellator opportunity and them [ __ ]
wouldn't find me a fight they signed a
contract saying able to find me for
fights in two years two years went by I
only had one fight with him and I was
begging I was begging them for fights
like give me one give me one and they
just kept putting me on the back burner
come [ __ ] you know [ __ ] you put you
know we got we got other people fighting
you know other bigger people worry about
so just piss me off well two years goes
by that [ __ ] to him a long time and well
something wasn't going on right with
that company because they went under
that was wsof they went under bankrupt
whole world series of fighting yes wsof
yeah and that sound like it would go
under yeah almost
and they went under well dude calls me
and starts begging me hey sign over to
uh and this is after being a contract
bad for two years begging them provide
some never calling you contacting you
and he says he calls me one day and says
hey man you want to be a millionaire I'm
like what's up you know like what's
going on he says well we're doing a new
tournament and if you just sign this new
contract you can be a millionaire that's
what he says work for work and I'm
thinking no [ __ ] this neat I'm out
because once the company goes under my
contracts void you know and he's sitting
there tell me you could be a millionaire
this time next year you could be a
millionaire you and and sure enough pfl
is doing great I don't know where
they're getting their money from though
I don't either I think they're gonna go
bankrupt too but as far as right now he
was right right so he was right he
wasn't lying but during that period of
time I'd already had he was it was not
getting that a bad experience with him
and so he just calls me up one day after
not calling me for months not answering
my texts and [ __ ] and then he says do
you want to be a millionaire yeah I'm
just thinking artists some
get-rich-quick it's like yes Sullivan or
something like somebody bringing that
big check to your house on a commercial
Reader's Digest or sometimes yeah and so
I instantly got out of that contract and
then I went to the Ultimate Fighter mmm
and then I signed a six fight to go on
Ultimate Fighter you had to sign a six
fight deal and so I was three fights
through it and that's when you
I guess typically renegotiated about
three fights or half way and so that's
what I've done and they offered me
almost double and so I took it you know
and yeah I'm happy with know you know
because even if you win that that the
UFC has more exposure
mmm-hmm as most exposure out all the
even if I would have won that million
dollars it's not as uh everybody knows
it's not the same as the UFC
yeah the UFC is the best of the best
Lance Palmer's not the best 145 he might
be the richest now you know do you feel
good about the choices you've made so
far I mean it seemed like you wait a
while to take a fight you know it's like
are you more anxious now to speed that
up or you just still kind of you know
you still kind of set and kind of your
planning and stuff
I get like those premonitions about when
I should fight next and whenever I get
that feeling that's when I'll but I get
this feeling like okay it's time now and
just for whatever I just make up my mind
and this is what I want to do it and but
I just feel like after that last fight
there they're trying so hard to [ __ ]
push me they're like and look what
they've done this and I am ready I'm
telling you right now I could fight any
given [ __ ] day and on that for at 145
title and I have the ability to win I
don't just want to win I want to
dominate I want to be at the best of my
ability I want to do things correctly
progress and be the best that I can be
then I get there but they offered to
fight to me tomorrow the title fight
yeah I take it but what they're trying
to do is rush me into some fight like
they was trying to get me to fight in
February real quick you know and it
seems a little quick it's just a little
quick man because the white cuts hard on
you you know you lose 20 pounds in two
days and your stomach's [ __ ] up you're
not you know it's just like just gimme a
and here's another thing about training
for a specific opponent like you're
fighting somebody and two or three
months you do not develop the same as
you do when you're not focused on
someone when you're focused on somebody
yes you're developing but you're more
worried about continuously doing a
couple things because you know what
you're saying yeah of course like when
I'm fighting Matt sales
I'm not going working my karate you know
I'm really not I'm not uh you can't
train the same because you're training
for that effect or that [ __ ] and
yes you get very good it doing what
you're doing but it gets repetitious
yeah
it gets repetitious it gets boring and
it's by the time the fight gets there
you're just so [ __ ] ready to fight
the dude you know what you want to do
even practice it for months and it's
like it it kind of in the fight is fun
and everything but just the training is
fun too and I like going into training
knowing I can work whatever I want to
work and that's how I believe that I
develop myself that's how I work on my
weird [ __ ] you know that's how I get
good at twisters that's how I get good
at things that I do that a lot of other
people don't it's because I'm relaxed in
the gym I'm having fun I'm trying to
challenge myself
if I know I'm fighting mad cells I'm not
going out and [ __ ] you know doing
doing things to develop myself further
I'm more just like focusing on a few
things like I need to do this this and
this and that's gonna win me this fight
get my family this [ __ ] money and
that's what I have to do anything else I
consider like [ __ ] around you know
it's a it's like you're doing a big show
but then also go and work out a club and
you can just kind of do your thing you
go do a show you're like I want to give
them the best you always talk about it
yeah yeah you can practice on your own
same concept yeah it really is man it's
funny I thought about that it was like
sometimes out too if I know I'm trained
like just doing a tour or something you
have to keep doing a lot of the same
material and it'll evolve some yeah
but at a certain point at some of the
repetition gets to be a lot mm-hm
whereas it's nice when you don't have to
have a like a tape and a comedy special
or something or at certain tour and then
you could just be free yeah it's range
free to thing your terrain is free your
brain is free nothing yeah that that's
why I started that's why I'm in love
with is because of just having the phone
in the gym it's like a reset for me if I
you know well no matter what's going on
or going to gym and I have some fun it's
like okay releases these chemicals you
know you feel all good relax your
buddies are there and that's why I love
to do it you know
amen man the money some of the money
that you made you guys are what you guys
doing with it I'm invested in I got two
LLC's got a little bit of rent houses
going just trying to do you know and
they won't pay themselves off for
another 10 to 15 years but that's for
when I'm retired you know yeah so one
day hopefully them rent houses will pay
themselves off one of my teachers he's a
he's a financial buy
I'm probably gonna you know give him
some money putting some stocks just
because it's like a passive form income
I don't have to monitor it you know I
pay him a fee and he [ __ ] does all of
it
so I'm gonna do a little bit of that and
so those are some of my investments and
then I'm gonna build a little place like
a metal house like a pole barn I'm
building one at my place and then that's
gonna be able to store for welding a
cook shed or something for the kids to
stay in and for all the farming
equipment and a training facility I'm
putting a small gym at my place so like
I won't be able to do like everything
that you do with a regular gym and you
know I'm saying but if I just want to
have one or two buddies over to three
buddies over we could train right there
in my garage and so I'll be training at
my own place three four or five times a
week now I know so just extra training
I'll have all that and once that that
metal building gets built I'm gonna be a
farmer because I've got my equipment I
can store things right now if I got a
bunch of corn I wasn't [ __ ] have
anywhere to put it yeah fill up my
trailer with corn yeah you know have you
sleeping on it I'd make a joke about
that baby corny do one of my favorite
things was whenever the UH one of these
cameras beep Nick it was this one oh
that's okay cool um one of my favorite
things was sometime whenever they're
combine we were running a combine
through like the car through the fields
you know and going and jumping in all
that corn when it was filled up in there
man it was awesome emptying out into
these big like just like basically I
guess they're like what is like a like a
thing you put on the back of a
18-wheeler or something you know and
it's so the tops open and we just get in
there and [ __ ] just sit in there and
all that corn it smells like bread it
smelled like fresh baked bread
mmm you get in there and your lady
everything good with the lady
everything's good to go brother that's
awesome man and she has a couple of
children right yes she's got two kids
everything couldn't be any better
yeah it's going good nice man cool man
well um we just want to thank you for
coming on anything else you have that's
it that's it for me yeah thank you so
much thanks man best a lot into urine
much and I'm gonna cheer you on brother
Yeah right
yeah dude piss wherever you want your
price
[Music]
a little time for me to set that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]